Assalamu
alaykum.
Walaykum. Asalama.
My name is Muhammad Usman Khan and I'm
from Kashmir working in Delhi, NCR,
India. I want to ask Dr. Zak Naik that
when did you first come to know that
Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him is
mentioned in Hindu scriptures and what
was your reaction? I was really shocked
when I first came to know about it. As
I'm working with Hindus, I want to give
dawa to them. Can you give me a few tips
on how I should initiate this
conversation with them? I am enrolled in
dawa training program and I request you
please expedite the upload speed. I have
memorized a few of your references from
Hindu scriptures. But how can I get
basic knowledge so that it should not
give an impression that I have not read
these scriptures and I have just
memorized few passages. I want to become
a full-time D. Can you give me a few
contacts in Delhi or any part in India
who can help me in the same
mood Khan who's working in Delhi has
asked the question that maybe heard my
talk on Muhammad sallallahu alaihi
wasallam in the Hindu scriptures
and he asked me when did I first come to
know that prophet Muhammad was mentioned
in the Hindu scriptures because when he
came to me he was shocked as you know
that I was inspired by Shik Ahmed did
when I met him in 1997
and after a few Few years after that I
read this book by the title Muhammad
sallallahu alaihi wasallam in the world
religious scriptures and another book
Muhammad sallallahu alaihi wasallam in
Hindu scriptures written by Vidyari
written by Hindu and this was in the
early '90s maybe early '90s exactly I
don't remember early '9s or mid '90s and
even I was shocked no one had told me
before that uh prophet Muhammad's peace
be upon him was mentioned in the
scriptures and if you of course I knew
about prophet Muhammad mentioned in the
Bible. I knew many prophecies and when I
compared between the prophecies
mentioned of Muhammad sallallahu alaihi
wasallam in the Bible and the prophecies
the Hindu scriptures the prophecies the
Hindu scriptures were multiple times
more more and Muhammad sallallahu alaihi
wasallam mentioned by name multiple
times more multiple times more in the
Hindu scriptures than the Bible. Bible
okay you can memorize all the verses and
and the references but in Hindu
scriptures there are too many hundreds
in the Bible there are less than that so
and I started using that in the question
at session the first time I gave a talk
on this topic similarities between Islam
and Hinduism I gave this talk I I
remember it was in 2004
in Azad Maidan in Bombay I remember Adat
Maidan that's a big it's a big ground
and that time it was one of the few
largest lectures at that time you know
18,000 people had come I know we had put
we had kept 18,000 chairs and about
20,000 people attended the talk and that
was the first talk which was on a on a
grand scale at that time in 2004
and after that I even gave a talk on
Mhamad sallallahu alaihi wasallam in the
religious vers scriptures and Mhammad
sallallahu alaihi wasallam the Hindu
scriptures I gave in Chennai and the
other parts
So all these three talks were closed in
2004 5 6 7. Yes it did shock me and when
I prepared for my talk on similar to
Islam and Hinduism I did a lot of
research because in Christianity it was
easy. Shake Dad made it so easy. You
read his books you can even debate with
the pope. He gave it to you on a
platter. But there were very few books
that were written on Hinduism and Islam.
And I think this was the only book I
could find. Prophet Muhammad's new
scriptures. Then I did my own research
and I did some own study and read the
scriptures. Then I prepared this talk on
similarities between Islam and
Christianity. Tried to divide it in my
own way comparing with the pillars of
Islam with the pillars of iman and you
know various things while answering many
question answer sessions you know
regarding what about jihad mentioned in
the Quran jihad mentioned in the Hindu
scriptures and all this what I've been
saying for the last few years. I
compiled and created and made and gave a
new talk similarities between Islam and
Hinduism. Regarding your last question
that you have you have enrolled in the
Dawa training program what the B is
referring to is our new platform
Alhidaya where we have a training course
called as let's become effective dies
international DA training program and we
have launched this platform in 2021
about 3 years ago and one of the courses
is which is a USP unique selling course
is let's become effective dies. This is
the recording of the training program we
did in Mumbai where we call 20 different
dies of students from 12 different
countries. We called them in Bombay. It
was for 45 days, 33 days of training was
there and we recorded this on 14 cameras
and now we are editing and releasing it.
We have a program of editing one one
part per month because unlike before
where we had a big team of 300 people
working in the media now our team is
smaller and these programs have got 14
cameras they are 4K and 8K very
voluminous very heavy so it takes
multiple times more so each course is
for about one and a half two hours of
recording so the recording time for
these courses take double than that than
a normal lecture and compared to us Dr.
Zakinag about four or five times more.
So we have a policy of releasing one
part per month and even that sometimes
we aren't able to do it. Sometime it
becomes one part in two months but of
course it will take years to release. So
you can follow this course, see this
course, follow the course guide. But as
far as your knowledge on Hinduism is
concerned, I would request you to see
few of my cassettes. Number one is
similarity between Islam and Hinduism.
Number two, Mhammed sallallahu alaihi
wasallam in the Hindu scriptures. And
then there are other question answer
sessions. So if you hear these talks of
mine and these questions, so if you go
through ask Dr. Zakir and see all the
question on Hinduism or see all my
questions on public lectures, we deal
with Hinduism. This inch shall give you
knowledge regarding a question that how
can I I memorize these verses but how
can I give the impression that I know a
lot. You should not give false
impression as a di you should not give
false impression. If you really want to
know read the scriptures I would advise
you to read the scriptures. If you read
Bhagat Gita it's not very voluminous
read it. So the references I've given
okay read the the references memorize
those references and read the book
Bhagat Gita or some of the books you
know so at least you have a idea or what
you can do if you cannot read the full
Rama and read the shorter version there
are many versions available short medium
long very long very voluminous so if you
want or you see my video cassettes and
you just repeat it if someone tells you
where you found it from I heard it from
Dr. Zakai is it authentic? You check it
up. It's been checked. So you don't have
to give a false impression that you are
Dr. Zakai. You don't have to give the
false impression that you have read
thousands of books on Hinduism. No, you
have to be honest. But some books are
which are popular and not very
timeconuming is the Bhagat Gita. It will
just take a few hours or little bit more
for you to read the full Bhagat Gita.
Even that has got different volumes etc.
But naturally the important books are
the Vedas. If you hear my talks you'll
find out. So you don't have to give a
false impression regarding do you have
any contacts in Delhi or India. You
don't require contacts. Everything is
available now on the social media. You
don't have to go to that city to learn
to meet him. You don't have to come
here. You can meet me on the social
media on the satellite on the television
to gain knowledge. Now it's easy
everything. The whole world has become a
global village. You can Google you can
see the videos. You can see peace TV.
You can see the speakers of peace TV.
And if you go on the social media if you
go on Alhida it's better al you can
select it is a social media which is a
paid social media unlike YouTube or or
Facebook we can only upload videos but
the way you can see on far superior we
have made it absolutely free and one
more good thing I'd like to mention that
in the last couple of months we have
launched the OTDT platform that's over
the top where we are available on
various different platforms not only on
the free social media we are available
on the mobile whether it's already there
for many years whether it be iOS or
whether it be Android whether on the web
whether it be Safari Chrome now we have
gone on various televisions we available
in Samsung on LG on Sony on hen on fire
on Roko so in the last few months we
have gone on OTT platforms over the And
this is a streaming which doesn't
require satellite. So we are there on
the satellite for many years mashallah
since 2006. So now it's about more than
18 years that we on the satellite. We
are there on the social media the free
social media. We went on the paid social
media that is Alida. Now recently past
few years we have gone OTT that's over
the top streaming. You can see on your
television you don't require the the
satellite you can come through the
internet you know and in this way the
reach will increase so surely you can
get a lot of knowledge you don't have to
have a satellite besides the pv beside
the free social media besides the paid
social media the OTT is also a very good
platform hope that answers the